we start with the commitment of expenses
we start with the fact that since 97
France
has growth above the European average
while before 97
it had a growth
below the European average
then I want to say we have to do this
you have to do this
all measures have advantages and disadvantages
the reality is that from 93 to 97
you did less well than us
and from 97 to 2002 we did better to say no
everyone has these numbers they are public
where we have been
the world champions of compulsory taxation
but that's not the point
is the growth is 99
I'll talk to you about growth
who was
the Minister of Finance with Sarkozy
it's terrible
that you don't want to talk about the subjects
we are talking about
we were talking about growth
mandatory problems
then if you don't want the croissants
mandatory they are today
exactly the same level as in 1997
accurate while in 97
they were normally above in 1993
while you were there they increased
while we were there they remained stable
now let's return to growth